in 18 days the cowboys help chris and
sophie stadium there will be no fans
present but the cowboys and the rams
will be playing there one of the
lingering questions and now look for
anyone out there
who is going to complain
that we're bringing
politics into sport we're not out there
looking for some angle we can wedge into
what otherwise is newsy
when you have one of the premier teams
in the national football league in the
dallas cowboys america's team
when that team has consistently gone
against what the league has said what
the league rules are regarding the
national anthem the league rule is that
the players can kneel they can
peacefully protest if they want to the
cowboys have always kept their players
from doing it usually by force of will
the will of jerry jones so the last we
heard from jones after an extended
silence was this confusing monologue
when he had a the great conference with
grace monologue saying grace grace grace
grace grace grace do it with grace right
and and we don't know what that means
well we got a little more insight
yesterday now that jerry jones is back
to doing twice per week on 105.3 the fan
in dallas yesterday he was asked
specifically about his plans for the
anthem policy here we go
i thought you did a nice compromise when
this first came up in arizona
and you guys kneeled before the anthem
and then you stood for the anthem
am i reading between the lines correctly
in in thinking that you're trying to
come up with a similar compromise
instead of saying yes everyone can kneel
they want or or the other side you're
trying to come up with a little balance
there like you did against the cardinals
yes you are
that's fair
and uh that
at the end of the day was a recognition
that we support our players i knelt with
our players as you know on a personal
basis but as a team
we all knelt together before the anthem
and we stood for the anthem to
recognize
what its symbol is to
america and i thought that was good and
that's the kind of thing that
we'll be looking to see if we can
implement
i got two observations yeah the first
one is kind of uh peel back the curtain
what does my spider sense tell me from a
media standpoint and i love the guys on
105 3 the fan in dallas i'm on there
from time to time with sean and rj the
way that question was set up yes
that question i believe
someone from the cowboys told them to
ask it that way that's just my instinct
from 20 years of doing this and being on
radio and dealing with hosts i not that
not that i
tell anybody anytime hey make sure you
ask the question this way but i
understand and i believe that at times
that happens and just the way it came
out
setting it up because the guy was
throwing a dart that just so happened to
hit the bullseye and the bullseye is
they're looking to have a compromise
where any kneeling happens before the
song is played and then when the song is
played everyone is standing at attention
toes on the line the way jerry jones has
always wanted it to be chris is that the
way you read that though the compromise
and that that that's what he's trying to
say is that he wants something like that
you don't think he's trying to look for
a new compromise i mean something else
that's different this time around i mean
that's kind of what maybe maybe you're
right mike i'm not trying to say no i
just didn't take it like that totally is
what i'm saying yeah i they're looking
for something that will result in
everyone standing for the anthem and you
know we went through this a few years
ago where teams were trying different
things to give their players an
opportunity to use the limited platform
before a game starts
to to express themselves and part of the
reality is there aren't many
opportunities short of doing it on the
field during the game which i don't
think anybody wants for someone to
express themselves and to the extent and
this goes back to the aryan foster
comments that i
that really crystallized the issue for
me we played those earlier this year he
was on pardon my take when the george
foster george floyd excuse me murder had
happened aryan foster was on
and he he explained that the anthem the
flag means different things for
different americans and it's all based
upon their own individual experiences in
this country right and for some
it evokes a sense of pride and
sentimentality and patriotism that
compels us to stand i stand my
grandparents came to this country in
search of a better life for themselves
their children their grandchildren and
so on and it's worked so that's what it
does for me but i can understand that
there would be some people that see
the flag and they think of their
experience their family's experience
right
there the experience of their ancestors
of their people who a lot of struggles
weren't necessarily brought over
voluntarily right right didn't get to
choose to come yep and and it's a
different perspective so that's the
moment
that's the moment for that to manifest
itself and jerry jones successfully was
able in 2016 and 2017 to steer it
away and even last remember when robert
quinn became a cowboy robert quinn was
one of the few that was putting a hand
in the air right a fist in the sky
during the anthem and they steered him
away from that and i feel like and this
gets this is the same mentality chris
that we see operate when it's time to
get a contract done
jerry jones throws his arm around you
has that heart-to-heart man-to-man talk
and he convinces you to see it his way
right and i feel like after years and
years and years of having that ability
that skill set that charisma work for
him he's going to try it one more time
and he's going to try to pull it off and
get his guys to choose to stand for the
anthem by coming up with some other way
whether it's everyone takes any before
whether it's something whatever it is
something other than kneeling for the
anthem even though the league we just
had the commissioner come out and say
he fully supports if players choose to
protest during the anthem well it's
obvious jerry jones doesn't want them to
do that period and he's trying to come
up with something else yeah well i don't
think it's like the best look that the
league and the teams aren't on the same
page there i'll just say that right off
the bat and i think the second thing is
with jerry jones and then this you know
hey listen this is this is a a tricky
situation this isn't 2016. the climate
has changed the world is different right
now i mean i think there's a lot more
compassion
about the social injustice matter than
there was then now i know there's still
a lot of people that they don't want to
hear it you don't kneel for the anthem
and you know you don't disrespect the
country i understand that to a degree
but yeah i would echo the same
sentiments that you did mike that the
the country doesn't stand for you know
the same to everybody it's just it's
different that way and now you have the
recent events of what happened in
wisconsin and i just think there's more
passion
within the players right now to where i
don't know if jerry jones is going to be
able to pull this one off to where he's
going to be able to tell his guys all
right
let's kneel before the anthem or
something like that listen he talked
about grace you know he talked you know
you talk about grace well grace
compromise you know maybe this is a
maybe he's the guy to do it maybe you
should be the guy to lead us through
this jerry and find a way to where you
can please both sides maybe one set of
your team is standing up and saluting
the flag the other set is kneeling down
with you know
army veterans and and other people that
are in service and they're holding their
hand to show like hey it's okay maybe
this is how you bring america together
something like that i hope it's
something like that because i don't
think it's right if he squashes players
first amendment rights in a time right
now where yeah things are dicey and it's
not you know all you know
better roses for african americans or
black people or people of color in our
country and uh i just have a hard time
thinking he's going to be able to thread
this needle here with this one and
you're on to something i think with this
disconnect between the league and the
teams because the league is the teams
and it's not enough in my view for the
commissioner to say one thing and then
the teams to do whatever the hell they
want especially if
jerry jones is operating from the
mindset of he wants to placate the
people who refuse to separate
kneeling during the anthem from
disrespect a flag military and country
because the commissioner earlier this
week
put that issue to bed for the entire
league if he's truly the commissioner if
he's truly in charge of the league if
it's his name on the football and not
jerry jones's name on the football once
the commissioner tells emmanuel ocho
it's not about the flag the message here
what our players are doing is being
mischaracterized these are not people
who are unpatriotic they're not disloyal
they're not against our military in fact
many of those guys were in the military
and they are military family yeah what
they were trying to do is exercise their
right to bring attention to something
that needs to get fixed what they were
trying to do is exercise their right yes
to bring attention to something that
needs to be fixed and that misrep
misrepresentation of who they were and
what they were doing was the thing that
really nodded me that is roger goodell
yeah from just a couple of days ago the
manual art show how can any owner
suggest any path that would undermine
that message and and cave
to the people
who refuse to accept the way that roger
goodell has characterized it that that
to me is the core of the problem and
that's why i think what needs to happen
is the commissioner needs to call jerry
jones and say stop it stop it don't try
to reach a compromise don't try to
negotiate directly with your players on
this don't try to talk them out of it
dawn terry poe said he's going to kneel
let him kneel anybody else wants to
kneel let him know it's not enough to
just fold your arms and and grit your
teeth and bite your tongue and and and
you know give them a dirty look while
they're doing the thing that they have a
right to do
if you truly support them you say
whatever you want to do is fine we
support you that's the attitude that
needs to come from every team otherwise
it's a horribly mixed message that every
member of the cowboys roster is probably
trying to figure out what the hell the
rule really is yeah well yes you're
right it's actually shocking you know
the fact that the nfl
usually so shows such great uniformity
like with these type of subjects and for
this one
yeah it seems like it's kind of on the
team to do whatever they want and you
know i don't know if i necessarily agree
with that you know you're right this is
a league-wide matter this is affecting
our league it's affecting our players
personally you know and then of course
in their communities too and where they
grew up and everything like that so
there's got to be a sensitive spot there
you know jerry jones you know i know we
talked about this last week when we
finally or two weeks ago when we finally
heard from him right you know people
were starting to think like oh is he
insensitive you know maybe he's
insensitive to the social justice issues
and things like that you know no he's
not i don't i don't believe he is he he
no he knows what's going on and i think
he really cares for people and black
people and african-american players i
mean he's he's amazing that way we
talked about that house he has so many
guys around him that he takes care of
through the years that were played from
15 20 years ago third you know whatever
it may be so he's amazing that way but
and we know he's american and he wears
the flag you know right next to his
heart and he's all about it and i get it
and he's kind of the american dream but
hey jerry
you know
be the american maybe that shows
you know the americans that you're
talking about mike that believe the
kneeling is just disrespectful to the
anthem
and
not about the social injustice and then
it's something bigger than that you know
jerry show those americans the way that
this is okay that those guys that are
kneeling down they are great americans
too
they're great americans and like you
said a lot of them come from houses of
military or things like that you know so
this is not insensitive they do things
for the military services in their free
time for charity and all of that so they
love and respect the military but
there's an issue here and to me that's
where i would call on jerry jones
because the spotlight's on him right now
with dallas cowboys being the americas
team few guys speaking out we've heard
don terry po gerald mccoy all these kind
of things where yeah everybody's gonna
want to see how he reacts and right now
he's kind of like that shining beacon
for the nfl like see like all right
what's he gonna do because this is gonna
be the loudest message sent on week one
and i just hope he uh takes the right
approach here yeah on sunday night
football on nbc when the rams and the
cowboys get together at the rams new
stadium where no fans will be to react
to whatever it is that happens on the
field and i i know that jerry jones is a
master salesman of his brand of his team
and his attitude has always been any
publicity is good publicity as long as
they get your name right i hope i hope
that he isn't using this as a way to
attract attention to the cowboys because
this isn't the kind of attention you
want no the nfl doesn't want or need one
of its teams one of its flagship teams
to be the center of this controversy of
will they or won't they be allowed to
kneel during the anthem will jerry jones
do what the commissioner wants him to do
i mean it's very interesting from the
perspective of an observer but it's not
the kind of thing the nfl should want
they should want to nip this in the bud
we shouldn't be talking about it
i
am going to talk about whatever the top
story of the day is in this first
segment and because it's the cowboys
because it's this unresolved issue that
from the league's perspective is
resolved chris it's supposed to be
resolved
and
and for the cowboys it's not it's like
the league says here's the official
football and the cowboys are saying well
maybe we'll use that ball maybe we'll
bring our own ball maybe we want to use
the college ball maybe but you know
we'll see
that that's not helpful for anybody
especially at a time that as you've
mentioned
it's different
we see teams we see players who are
empowered and emboldened to speak out
they canceled practice yesterday for the
detroit lions and i thought when i first
saw they canceled practice there's some
sort of an outbreak of the coronavirus
no the players did not want to practice
did not want to focus on football wanted
to focus on social justice because of
what happened to jacob blake in kenosha
wisconsin on sunday night period no
practice for the lions yesterday they
came out and met with the media together
they had banners they had messages they
are sending
that signal they are using that platform
and instead of waiting until
the national anthem before their week
one game they decided to press pause on
their preparations for the season to
take a day and shut it down to make sure
people understand what they're concerned
about and that change needs to finally
come that every time we think change is
coming we see another one of these
videos that makes us think that the
message is lost on the people who are
carrying around lethal force in the
palms of their hands you mentioned
ontario chris yeah and don terry poe
does plan to kneel and he has said he
wants to talk about it directly to jerry
jones jerry responded here's what he had
to say
i just wanted like i said just getting
there and talked to him i asked a couple
players how is he and all of them has
pretty much told me the same thing like
yeah he's willing to talk he's always
ready he's not too busy
so uh that was encouraging from that
aspect but like i said it's still worse
to be had between us two so we will do
that the time that we have the first
game i will left a visit with him more
than likely on an individual basis
uh all of that will come to play and
he'll have
we'll have a plan that
recognizes what he's trying to do and
the way he's trying to do it
and everybody's going to be sensitive to
on the other hand be sensitive to what
it is we're about we're out there to
ask the fans to uh follow be attentive
to us
and we're well aware of
the issue and well aware of
where
dallas cowboys fans are on it
all of that will be put in the hopper
and we'll see how we handle
again that just underscores the point
chris that
it's now an issue it's now something
we're going to be paying attention to
and it shouldn't be this way it should
be the commissioner on the phone with
jerry jones asap it should have happened
yesterday it should have happened as
soon as the words came out and we don't
know they're not going to announce it
jerry jones and roger goodell aren't
going to issue a joint statement saying
that roger goodell called him up and
said stop it but roger goodell needs to
call him up and say stop it and i
understand it's a delicate balance even
though the commissioner is in charge of
the entire sport
there's a group of owners that are in
charge of him right and on some
occasions he's got to stand up to them
and that's really the question here and
this gets to the heart of the
uncomfortable conversation that he had
with emmanuel acho on emmanuel's
excellent digital series and also the
questions raised by jim trotter of nfl
network an employee of roger goodell who
said maybe it wasn't uncomfortable
enough
this is the uncomfortable thing that
roger goodell needs to face now is he
willing to stand up to a powerful owner
and say
stop it
your players are permitted to do
whatever they want and you will support
them and you will go on 105 3 the fan in
dallas on friday
usual spot tuesday and friday and say
i've thought about it i've talked to the
league about it and you know what i'm
i'm i'm i'm reversing course whatever
the players want to do is fine with me
and stick to that not just make it lip
service i don't think that's going to
happen
that's what needs to happen now yeah i
mean you would like to think that but i
don't think anybody's going to call
jerry jones and tell him what to do with
the dallas cowboys i just think well
then he's the commissioner yeah and he's
the commissioner well right period he's
that you know they say all the time i
remember when i was in school and we
were talking about the existence of god
and like whoever put this in motion is
god well what if there's somebody who
put him in motion then that's god but
what if something put that in motion
then that's god you keep going until you
get to the one that starts it if roger
goodell can't call jerry jones and say
stop it then jerry jones is the
commissioner well i mean i i don't know
if
i i don't deny that to a degree i mean i
think there's a lot of people around the
nfl for a long time that thought really
the de facto commissioners were jerry
jones and robert kraft i mean basically
you know i don't know if that stands
true anymore with you know them get up
there in age and you know of course you
know his sons are taking over more of a
role with the team and all that but you
know he's he's definitely with this
conversation gonna make guys
uncomfortable in his locker room because
they're gonna feel like they're being
boxed into a corner here right and this
is just a time in right now where you
know again
things have
flamed up again because of wisconsin and
you're gonna see more and more passion
and there's gonna be more and more
conversations going on in nfl locker
rooms and guys are gonna be talking
about what are we gonna do week one so
if jerry jones doesn't want guys to
kneel and do something like that
he's gonna have to come
if i'm a player in that locker room he's
gonna have to come with some hell of a
compromise to make us feel like okay
yeah we can't do this and we're doing
this not because we're disrespecting the
country we're doing this because here we
are four years later and we're still
seeing tons of unarmed black
african-american men get shot and killed
i mean you know why why we couldn't
shoot the tires out of the car or use a
taser i don't know seven bullets in a
guy's back i don't you know it just
seems a little weird to me a little
so
you know that's a this is a sensitive
subject and
you know this hits home for our
african-american players in the nfl
they're from a lot of these communities
where they've seen this crap happen for
a long time so he's thin ice here with
this one and he better come up with some
good compromise or i think he's going to
have a lot of players you know giving
him the side eye and not looking at him
the same way that maybe they used to
before all this went down
yeah look i i
i think it's something that
needs to be addressed immediately by the
league by the cowboys it it sends a
horribly mixed message at a time when
there should be nothing other than
a unanimous consistent position by the
nfl that doesn't mean everybody kneels
for the anthem we're not saying that
everyone should be allowed to make their
choice and support means you're truly
allowed to make your choice not well if
you really have to do it or anything
passive aggressive like that and no
efforts behind the scenes to persuade
someone to make a different choice let
them make the choice that they believe
is right for them each individual player
coach staff member everyone who's on the
sideline for that anthem and that's what
it needs to be it needs to be
unconditional unequivocal support it
cannot be any type of effort to persuade
them otherwise and and it's like there's
two different languages being spoken by
the league office and by jerry jones and
there's no other there's no
it's doing this no one else which makes
it even more glaring chris yeah no i
think that's the big thing is he's
really the only guy i think all owners
are
okay
hey this is an issue in our country and
you know our players have
every right to be upset about it and
they're going to let their play their
players express themselves but jerry
jones that does not seem to be the case
and uh yeah the our eyes are on him now
to see what he does and how he handles
this situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports